hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar today mapping nuclear
exosome targeted poly a tails the three
prime end RNA sequencing I am Brenda
Kelly Kim elaborate and I'll be
moderating this session today today's
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by Lex again lexa
gen transcriptomics and next-generation
sequencing company focusing on
development of products and able
incompletes transcriptome sequencing
lexa gen was founded in 2007 it is based
in Vienna Austria and has a subsidiary
in New Hampshire United States to learn
more please visit us WWE exigence com
now let's get started you can pose
questions to the speaker during the
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind to do so simply type them into the
Q&A box which will open when you click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you experience any technical problems
seeing or hearing the presentation just
click on the support button found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left I'd
now like to present today's speaker
Kevin Roy Kevin obtained his PhD
molecular biology and the laboratory of
dr. Guillaume Sean fro at UCLA there he
studied environment dependent RNA
degradation pathways in yeast and
developed high-throughput method
to map poly a + 3 prime ends short-lived
RNA species he has a strong background
in yeast genetics and molecular biology
as well as in high-throughput sequencing
techniques and data analysis he is
currently a postdoctoral scholar in the
laboratory of dr. lars Steinmetz in the
Department of Genetics at Stanford
University his current interests include
high-throughput systems genetics the
focus on how genetic variation interacts
with environment to produce phenotype
dr. Roy will now begin his presentation
hello everybody good morning to those of
you the the west coast and afternoon and
evening to those of you out of East
Coast and in Europe my name is Kevin Roy
and I am currently a postdoctoral
researcher at Stanford today I'd like to
talk first about RNA sequencing in
general and then focus on specifically
three prime end RNA sequencing and the
benefits that it exhibits for certain
studies and then I'd like to go into
some of the biology that we uncovered by
looking specifically at the nuclear axis
from targeted RNAs so first if we look
at what RNA sequencing can show us is it
really reveals what what portions of the
genome are expressed so in particular
whole transcript RNA sequencing is the
technique in which the entire transcript
is fragmented and then the regions are
our sequence individually and this
enables us to understand the transcript
structure so we can infer the start site
of the gene the end site as well as
where the transcript is spliced together
another important benefit of RNA
sequencing is that it allows us to
quantify the expression level of genes
across the genome so we can understand
how genes are expressed and how they are
regulated but whole transcript RNA
sequencing requires that many reads be
assembled across the gene in order to
in order to map its structure and so
this allows us to understand these
aspects of how the transcript is formed
but in some cases we might be interested
in three prime end sequencing and so why
would we want to perform three prime end
sequencing as opposed to the whole
transcript sequencing well three prime
minister cling is cost-effective and
sufficient because it counts only the
ends of the transcripts and only one
cdna is generated per transcript in
addition the differential expression
analysis so determining how the
expression level of different
transcripts in the sample has changed is
simpler for three prime and sequencing
because it's not complicated by the
length of the transcript and the
variation in detection across the
transcript furthermore three prime and
sequencing allows for the precise
mapping of cleavage and polyadenylation
sites giving insights into the
mechanisms that generate the alternative
three prime untranslated region
selection so for this particular gene
ynl 067 w you can see how the
traditional RNA seek and the three prime
end RNA seek provide different
advantages for understanding the
transcript so the the traditional RNA
seek actually does a fairly poor job of
capturing the ends of the transcript and
that's a no that's a consequence of how
these libraries are prepared the three
prime end sequencing however only
focuses on the three prime end and is
very efficient at detecting exactly
where these transcripts end so you can
see that with three prime and sequencing
there is one major polyadenylation site
but there are also a few a few other
poly-a sites in this transcript that
would not be well identified with the
traditional RNA seek method so if we
look at the house three prime end RNA
sequencing is accomplished it's a fairly
simple protocol and another advantage
over the whole transcript sequencing is
that the the library preparation is
quite quite efficient quite simple so
the first step in both the ala go dt
binding to the poly a tail that is
present on
rnase and this allows for the the
reverse transcriptase to generate a
single-stranded DNA from the RNA and
from there the library preparation is is
conducted with random priming of second
strand synthesis and then pcr
amplification with bar codes that allow
for multiplex type throughput sequencing
and so when we first started to perform
three pounds and sequencing and
wild-type yeast we we were able to get a
large number of reads using the quantity
platform and we obtained over ten
million reads for one sample in this
case and we noticed that we only roughly
half of the reads mapped to unique
positions within the genome and nearly
forty percent of the reads for mapping
to multiple positions and when we looked
at the fast q SI report on the
over-represented sequences in this in
this sequencing experiment we notice
that many of these sequences mapped to
the ribosomal RNA and so in this
particular case you're seeing the the
ribosomal RNA gene encoding ribosomal
RNA which is encoded by multiple copies
in the genome and a comparison of the
whole transcript sequencing which
results in background due to this
abundant transcript with the three prime
and sequencing reveals a hotspot that is
specific to three prime and sequencing
and this is a contaminant in the data
set and this actually correspondent to
thirty percent of all the reads in our
data set so if we zoom in on this hot
spot we can see that the all ago dt was
likely priming at these short stretches
of imperfect a's that typically had a G
or two in the middle and so from from
looking at the types of miss priming
that we were getting from this abundant
RNA we're able to determine that I'll go
dt can efficiently prime under the
conditions of our library prep and
it's stretch of 6 a's that can be
interrupted with up to 2 g's and the GT
base pair can be oh it's a wobble pair
and that explain why we were getting
some of these contaminant reads so we
look back at the protocol we we noticed
that one of the critical steps is the
hybridization of the ala go dt primer to
the poly a tail and so a major factor in
how the priming workers the temperature
of the river of the hybridization and
the reverse transcription so what we did
for this step was we decided to raise
the temperature from 37 degrees to 42
degrees and perhaps more importantly we
keep the samples on the heating block
during this entire step and in addition
one other modifications we made was to
increase the cycles from 12 to 15 cycles
and so now by by the slight
modifications we are able to obtain a
huge increase in the quality of the
library and decrease the internal
priming so here you can see the results
of the sequencing library at 42 degrees
with the reverse transcription step
versus the 37 degrees step and so now
instead of fifty-five percent of the
reads mapping uniquely we now have over
ninety percent and this corresponded to
a more than ten fold a roughly ten fold
reduction in the internal priming and so
now we notice the over-represented
sequences were much lower in abundance
and in this case there is one sequence
that popped out to us which was a large
stretch of T's and so this particular
artifact we're not sure exactly the
source of it but it may be due to
content select contamination with a read
one primer that did not contain the poly
TN so based on all these artifacts we we
developed a computational filter that
would improve the quality of the three
prime ends that we identified and so the
first filter utilizes the six base pairs
downstream of the poly a site and
looks for whether or not they're our age
and GS and if there are more than 4 a's
and no c or t so in other words up to 2
g's and 4 a's then this is likely an
artifact and so we screened those sites
out another filter looked at the 18 base
pairs downstream of the poly-a site and
if this stretch of 18 nucleotides
contain greater than 12 A's or equal to
12 days this was also likely to be a
Miss priming event and so we screened
these out as well and due to the poly T
reads that we identified another filter
we employed was to look at the 18 base
pairs upstream of poly a side and we we
would filter the these poly-si as if
there were more than 50 nays 15 or more
days and this window as well so after
employing these three filters if we look
at the reads from these libraries the
reads mapping to non open reading frame
regions and so these are reads that the
that are mostly in the three prime utr
region where we expect the filter that
we employ filters out roughly 700,000
out of the 5 million reads and the most
of the reads are filtered with this
downstream six base pair AG filter the
other two filters remove roughly ten
percent of that sixty thousand reads so
if we look at the reads that we're
actually mapping to within open reading
frame regions we noticed that many of
these Reed's were were likely internal
miss priming events and so this filter
actually removes almost half of these
reads so 66,000 are removed and the
remaining 110,000 are could could
represent a real internal
polyadenylation events and then the
other filter removes only 6000 so in
total the using these computational
filters in combination with the modified
library preparation protocol resulted in
a higher confidence calling of poly a
size and ninety-eight percent of the
poly-a sites identify
we're not in open reading frame region
which is consistent with what we know
about the polyadenylation in the cell so
here's an example of that ribosomal RNA
hot spot where if we look at all the
poly-a sides this actually corresponds
to thirty percent of the entire reads in
the sequencing library were mapped to
just a small region of less than 50 base
pairs and if we look at the
computational filter it was able to
remove the majority of these reads now
this is the library prepared with 37
degree reverse transcription when we
increase the reverse transcription to 42
degrees this contamination to begin with
was much less so three percent of all
the reads and the filter if you look at
the passing poly a side filter it
removed the majority of these so we
think that would these these two steps
improving the protocol with a higher
temperature reverse transcription and
computationally removing likely
artifacts from the poly-a sites we are
improving the confidence in three prime
end calling so now we wanted to get some
of the biology in our lab is interested
in the RNA processing of transcripts and
in particular the different types of RNA
processing that exists in the cell so
the the ends of genes are mostly
determined by the RNA processing signals
so the five prime end of the gene is
where the transcription begins and the
three prime end of a gene is usually not
where the transcription ends but it's
where the transcript is actually cut or
processed and much of the RNA and the
cell is stabilized and exported but a
large fraction is also degraded and
we're interested in the pathways that
that make this choice of either
stabilizing or degrading the RNA so the
cleavage and polyadenylation machinery
is the primary mechanism for stabilizing
RNA and this is used on the protein
coding genes to make messenger RNAs that
are ready for translation however a
large fraction of the transcription in
the cell is actually degraded right away
and so these transcripts one of the
major mess
to degrade these transcripts uses the
nerd one and nab three RNA binding
proteins and these are RNA binding
proteins to recognize short sequences
and they result in the degradation of
the transcript and then there are a
couple of other mechanisms that also
degrade transcripts one of them is the
rnase three endonuclease another one
that was recently uncovered is its
physical roadblocks in the DNA so DNA
binding proteins that just block RNA
polymerase progression also lead to the
degradation of the transcript so what we
noticed was that all of these different
non-canonical termination pathways they
lead to the degradation of the
transcript through a common pathway that
involves first polyadenylation by a by a
poly a polymerase different from the
canonical poly a polymerase that poly a
polymerase is called trf for and it is a
part of the [ __ ] complex and that is
normally in wild-type cells followed by
rapid degradation by the nuclear excess
come and our RP 6 subunit is is
important for initiating that
degradation so if we look at the the
detailed mechanism involves the addition
of an all ago a tail and this all ago a
tail is then transferred through the
nuclear exosome like a thread and the
the cord part of the nuclear exosome
accommodates this thread and the disk
three subunit at the bottom of the
exosome catalyzes the complete
degradation of these transcripts so what
we reason was that if we can inactivate
the nuclear exosome we will stabilize
these transcripts and we can then look
at the three prime end sequencing of
these unstable transcripts and by
comparing these two wild-type cells we
can gain a good picture of how the the
transcripts are degraded by looking at
the three prime ends and so when we
first started this project we read there
were a couple of
options for for RNA sequencing of the
three prime ends and one of them that
was attractive was the direct RNA
sequencing which which conceptually is
very simple it just involves the single
molecule sequencing of RNAs directly
from their natural poly a tails the
other method is this the quantity to be
prime man a library prep method which I
just spoke about and if we look at the
pros and cons of these the pros of the
direct RNA sequencing or that there are
no sample manipulation or library prep
involved there's no reverse
transcription or amplification bias
however the pros for the classic method
is that it's it's incredibly
cost-effective in comparison and
multiplexing is possible and there
because it's utilizing the Illumina
sequencing platform long reads of 50 or
even 100 nucleotides are possible in
there a few errors in comparison and the
cons of the direct RNA sequencing or
that the multiplexing is not possible
it's in comparison to quantity an
expensive and slow method and the short
reads of 20 to 25 nucleotides are also
error prone the Quantic method can have
internal priming and AG rich sequences
and as it involves pcr amplification
there is the potential for amplification
bias and also the library size selection
can introduce bias but these steps can
all be mitigated so if we if we look at
the direct RNA sequencing results and
what they reveal for these samples when
we inactivated the nuclear exosome we
can see that a substantial fraction of
the transcripts map to the three prime
utr which is what we expect for the
protein coding mrnas however we see that
in these cells a large fraction of the
transcripts come from other categories
of genes in particular the snow RNA
genes which are small nucleolar rnas
that are involved in ribosome biogenesis
and we also see these other cryptic
transcripts in green the cryptic
unstable transcripts and these other
categories of transcripts that have
it will define function but that our
pervasively transcribed by the RNA
polymerase in comparison wild-type cells
exhibit nearly ninety percent of the
reads mapping to the three prime UTR so
we we figured that this was an effective
approach for understanding the nuclear
access our targets and we wanted to
compare it to the Carkeek method so
here's a comparison of the exact same
RNA sample sequence on the kalam seek
platform and you can see that we get a
larger fraction of reads mapping to the
three prime etrs and the the relative
ratios of the other categories are
similar and so we're not quite sure of
the reason for this discrepancy in the
percentages of the and the percentages
that we see in the different categories
but we think though it may have to do
with the the higher error rate and the
lower read length the shorter read
length of the direct RNA sequencing
resulting in three prime utr regions not
mapping as well so if we look at the
snow rnase these small nuclear nuclear
RNA switching which as a class of genes
represented a large fraction of the
cellular poly a + RNA after nuclear
exosome inactivation we can see as a
class with the meta-analysis two
prominent peaks and so that what
meta-analysis does here is that it takes
individually each of the 77 snow RNA
genes and what we're doing is
normalizing the total sequencing signal
in the region of these genes and after
normalizing to the same arbitrary
constant we can sum them up and by
looking at them all together we can see
trends that we might miss by looking at
any individual RNA and so here we can
see that the two methods direct RNA
sequencing and the Clontz seek
sequencing actually give pretty pretty
good agreement in the relative location
of these Peaks so we can see one p right
into the mature 3 prime end of these
neurones and we can see another p25
nucleotides downstream after that we see
this broad range of signal and that that
broad range of signal we think is we
initially suspected was the actual
termination product from the nns pathway
then there in one nab three termination
pathway and the the 25 nucleotide blank
peek we notice matched the the length
that is accompanied by the nuclear
exosome channel and so we suspected that
perhaps what we're seeing here is a
processing intermediate so that we
haven't fully inactivated the nuclear
exosome in in these previous experiments
we deleted the RRP 6 subunit at the top
here in red and however in the absence
of our p6 the nucleosome still have some
function and so in order to fully
inactivate it we also had to to get rid
of the the RRP 44 or otherwise known as
disc 3 function however dis three is an
essential gene and so we can't we
couldn't simply delete it so what we've
decided to do was we we used a
conditional depletion of this three with
the anchor Aweigh method so the anchor
Aweigh method is a very effective method
in yeast to rapidly deplete nuclear
proteins and move them into the
cytoplasm and the reason it's so
effective is that it involves on a very
abundant ribosomal protein RPL 13a that
is modified with a tag called fkb p12
and in the absence of rapamycin its
ligand there's no interaction between
our PL 13 a set fkb p12 subunit of our
PL 13 a and the protein of interest
however the protein of interest in the
presence of rapamycin it's tagged with
the frb binding domain rapidly forms a
complex with the FK BP 12 and this is a
very stable complex that results in the
export of this protein into the
cytoplasm and so this this
has been shown before and we thought
would want seek method we could
multiplex many samples using Newton's
that are modified with this method and
so we conditionally depleted the disc
three catalytic subunit of the nuclear
exosome in addition to the r 4 p-6
subunit so what you can see here is that
the depletion of our fe 6 alone
resembles the results that we obtained
the deletion of this gene but if we
deplete both our RP six and the dist
three subunit we we get a larger
fraction of reads that are not mapping
to three prime utr s but instead our
mapping to these other classes of
transcripts that are known to be
targeted by the nuclear exosome so we we
went forward with this approach and what
we did was we looked at the total
nuclear exosome targeted rnas and we
wanted to determine where they were
mapping to and and what what types of
genes are targeted by these by the
nuclear facility was we clustered these
poly a sites and we chose to cluster
poly a sites that were within 20 base
pairs of one another and these clusters
were then separate when they were
separated by greater than 20 base pairs
were called as different clusters and so
we shows a cut-off of two reads per
million for the clusters for the cluster
peaks and so when we looked at where
these clusters were mapping we notice
that most of them were mapping in in
three prime three prime utr and
intergenic regions and when we fully
inactivated the nuclear exosome by
depleting both subunits the intergenic
region clusters Werdum regions as well
they were previously going to be
targeted by the nuclear exosome so the
fact that we identified clusters in
intergenic regions in regions that
weren't previously on
known to have transcripts led us to
believe that the quantity method was
giving us unprecedented resolution and
identifying the transcription that leads
to degradation so we first we looked at
the combined depletion of both of these
subunits of the nuclear episode and what
we notice was that this 25 base pair
peak so if we look downstream of the
snow rnase in the RR p6 depletion alone
we can see that the peak is predominant
along with the peak at the mature 3
prime end when we remove both subunits
of the nuclear episome we can see that
the the plus 25 base pair peak is
substantially reduced and so this led us
to believe that we were effectively in
activating the nuclear exosome and these
data led us to propose the following
pathway for the 3 prime end maturation
of snow rnase and so the tripping
termination depends on the nns pathway
the nerd one nap three RNA binding
proteins which recruit the Sun 1
helicase this lead to the release of the
transcript and termination of
transcription what happens first is that
a short poly a tail is added to these to
these precursors this poly a tail has
been degraded by the nuclear exosome in
a specific mode of degradation that
involves the disc 3 x1 nuclease however
this exonuclease is paused when it
reaches + 25 base pairs because the the
central channel of exosome is physically
blocked by the 3 prime end structure of
these RNA and after that the nuclear
confirm disengages and another poly a
tail is added by the [ __ ] complex which
is then fully degraded by the RRP 6
subunit of a nuclear exercise so in
order to fully inactivate the nuclear
exosome depleting both of these subunits
was really the most important strategy
and so the next thing we wanted to
determine was if all
dt is actually priming these
non-canonical poly a tails efficiently
so that we are obtaining an unbiased
view of these transcripts we were
concerned that if the tails were too
short perhaps we're only seeing some of
these non-canonical targets and not not
a full picture so normally in wild-type
cells the canonical mrna poly a tails
are quite long in comparison there 30 to
80 nucleotides along the yeast the
non-canonical poly a tails are quite
short in comparison so these can contain
between 1 and 12 a's and we knew from
previous work that after in activating
the nuclear exosome the [ __ ] poly a
complex actually continues to add short
stretches of age at a time and so that
the a tail can get lengthened but we
weren't sure if this was Universal
occurring on all transcripts so what we
did was we decided to employ an in vitro
polyadenylation treatment so we took
purified rnas from a cell from either
the wild-type cells or the cells in
which we inactivated the nuclear exosome
and you can see with the ? we weren't a
one hundred percent sure if the nuclear
exosome targeted rnas were obtaining
long enough poly a tails for us to see
all of them and so what we did to answer
this question was we treated these rnas
with ATP in equal equal ride poly a
polymerase and this added universally
wrong poly a tails of over a hundred a's
and so we added poly details to mature
rnase that normally don't contain them
and we also added poly a tails to the
nuclear echo some exosome targeted RNA
is to to make sure that we were
detecting all of them in addition to
that mrnas also were or lengthened by
this procedure and so first if we look
at the the signal downstream of the snow
rnase when we inactivate the nuclear
exorcism we see a number of peaks that
that seem to have that
highest level of signal in the 200 to
300 base pair region downstream of the
snow rnase and what we did was after we
in vitro polyadenylated all of the RNA
we see that now the by far the most
predominant signal is the mature 3 prime
end of these snow rnase mess because
most of the snow RNA in the cell is
mature Prospero process no learning but
if we block out that signal and instead
look at the the nuclear exosome targeted
poly ace we can see that the in vitro
polyadenylation treatment reveals
remarkably similar profile of these
unprocessed 3 prime end and so from
these data we could conclude that what
would really look what the quant seat
library preparation protocol is
efficiently priming these these these
nuclear after some targeted poly a tails
and so the next question we had to get
into more the biology was are these poly
entail transcripts that we identify upon
nuclear exosome inactivation really
representative of the true sites of
termination of RNA polymerase by the nns
pathway and so what we what we decided
to do is look at previous data in
combination with data that we were
obtaining so at first if we look at the
the signal upon the depletion of our RP
6 we can see the mature Pauline tail
peak the plus 25 nucleotide peak and the
peaks that were really interested in are
the ones downstream that a
representative of determination site so
if we inactivate the termination
mechanism in combination with the
nuclear exosome inactivation we can see
so we can do that by depleting the sin
one subunit as well so when we deplete
the sin one subunit we see a loss of
these termination petes however the
mature the mature peak in the
+ 25 nucleotide peak do not go away and
that confirms that these indeed are not
termination sites but rather the
processing site now if we look at
previous data that had examined aren't
inflam race to occupancy by chip in self
also have this the nerd one subunit of
the nns pathway inactivated we can see
that the regions where RNA polymerase
normally terminate it agrees well with
the regions that were identifying by the
three prime end sequencing method and
the peaks that we identify in our
sequencing methods to agree well with
the the inactivation of the nns pathway
and where the RNA polymerase seems to no
longer terminate as you can see in green
we also compared it to other data as
well that had looked at RNA polymerase 2
powered clip cross-linking trnas that
are bound to RNA polymerase 2 in the
wild-type cells as well as themselves
that have the nns pathway compromised
with either the sin one mutation in
activation or the nerd one in activation
and we can see that the nerd 1 and
activation gives a clear inflection
point where the RNA polymerase 2 is no
longer terminating and begins to
accumulate downstream the sun one
inactivation gives a higher level
throughout so it's harder to interpret
the termination site from from the Sun
one inactivation so when we looked at
other factors that might be involved in
termination we-we-we map these poly a
tails are on to the nucleosomal
occupancy and we notice that when the
nucleus of occupancy began to increase
downstream of this Nora name the the
major termination peeps were coinciding
with the nuclear with the nucleosome
occupancy Peaks how
we notice that a number of the peaks
upstream of that but downstream of the
plus 25 nucleotide p seem to be highly
predominant and we looked when we looked
at these we notice that these peaks were
directly upstream of DNA binding
proteins and so we could divide these
these two peaks depending on the
presence or absence of a DNA binding
protein in the immediate vicinity
downstream and so you can see by by
dividing these two classes of peace we
now we can we can clearly see two
distinct classes of termination of RNA
polymerase 2 so on the far right are the
peaks where we did not identify a DNA
binding protein downstream we can see a
much broader termination region that
peeps around 250 meters downstream in
the presence of DNA binding proteins the
termination Peaks are much sharper and
both of these termination peaks are
highly depleted when we remove the Sun
one factor from them from the nucleus
indicating that these are and
termination events that were identifying
and we can then in the meta-analysis we
can look at the RNA polymerase 2
occupancy at these peaks and we also
identify that what we're seeing with the
nuclear episome poly a tails agrees well
with the previous regions that have been
mapped by pulp to occupancy but the
advantage of the nuclear actress from
targeted poly a tails is that we get a
high-resolution view of where the
transcription is actually terminating
and so we we also in comparison with the
hard clip-on across from the RNA
cross-linking data we were also able to
verify that these ponytails were mapping
well with these data and so what we
could see is that as a class the non
roadblocked snow rnase without the DNA
binding proteins downstream appear to be
blocked by the nucleosome occupancy
whereas the road
no rnase in the middle panel at the
bottom contained these DNA resistant
footprints directly downstream of each
peak and so we could conclude that the
nns termination appears to require not
only RNA binding signal but also
obstacles in the DNA either DNA binding
proteins or nucleosomes and so we wanted
to take a step back and look at all of
the clusters that we identified with the
3 prime sequencing and so here we're
looking at all roughly 3,000 clusters
and we're separating them on the basis
of whether or not they have a DNA
assistant site and so when we map the
the pulp the RNA polymerase to occupancy
on these two data sets we see vastly
different behaviors so in the absence of
a downstream DNA's resistance site we
see the RNA polymerase 2 begins to
accumulate near the termination site
indicating pausing and then at the
termination site rapidly falls off the
within the presence of a downstream DNA
binding protein the accumulation of RNA
polymerase is much more pronounced at
the termination site and we can see that
when the RNA polymerase is an
inactivated with the send one or the
nerd one depletion from the nucleus that
RNA polymerase 2 occupancy is increased
at these termination size indicating a
lack of termination so when we look at
the non exosome targeted poly a tail so
these are the poly a tails and wild-type
cells that normally that are typically
on the protein coding mrna we can see
that this behavior is not observed and
so we can see that there is an
accumulation of RNA polymerase in the at
the ends of these chains at the three
prime processing sites and this is in
agreement with previous studies but we
don't see the same behavior so we we we
can conclude that we've identified that
the nns pathway utilizes these two
distinct modes of termination
and the three-prime in sequencing allows
us to precisely map exactly where the
RNA polymerase is terminating in the
case of these nuclear ekta some targeted
poly a tails and so what we also noticed
was that the same DNA binding proteins
that were blocking RNA polymerase were
previously shown to block DNA polymerase
and so it suggested that these DNA
binding proteins had some sort of
special ability that controlled both DNA
and RNA synthesis and so we we process
the previously mapped DNA three prime
end data and DNA replication occurs in
two directions because of the because of
the anti parallel nature of the double
helix and one of the directions in the
lagging strand called the lagging strand
synthesis involves repeated rounds of
DNA synthesis and the lagging strand
synthesis encounters the same roadblocks
that RNA polymerase doesn't so you can
see here when we map the nuclear after
some targeted poly a tails alongside the
Okazaki fragment three prime ends from
the lagging strand synthesis we can see
they map almost directly on top of each
other however there is a slight
difference in the in the location of the
peaks and so if we look at the TF 3b
transcription factor which binds DNA
upstream of tRNA genes we can see a nine
base pair difference in these peaks and
we thought perhaps this is a
characteristic signature of these
different modes of of roadblock a
different modes of DNA and RNA synthesis
and so to confirm that we looked at
another DNA binding protein called Reb
one that also brock's these these
synthesis modes and we saw the same
distance of nine base pairs from the
from the nuclear exome targeted poly a
tail to the Okazaki fragment 30 min and
so the
one cig method allowed us to map these
precise peaks and also enabled us to to
utilize many different mutants which you
see here in the colors at the bottom and
by by inactivating different genes we
were able to prove that these peeps are
indeed road blocked by the factors that
we've identified so in conclusion we
were able to determine that the with a 3
prime and sequencing that the
termination sites from the nns pathway
have different profiles depending on the
presence or absence of a DNA binding
protein so in the absence of a DNA
binding protein the termination occurs
over a broad region and in the presence
of a DNA binding protein there's a sharp
peak of termination that occurs that is
the location of that termination is
defined by the presence of the DNA
binding protein and so in other work
that I that I don't have time to go into
we're able to determine that the the
level of nerd 1 and nab three binding
sites in the RNA actually determine
whether termination will occur but that
this needs to be taken into contact with
the DNA binding protein so that if there
are a medium level of of these nerd
wanna nap three bindings types the in
the presence of a DNA binding protein
termination will occur but in the
absence of the DNA binding protein
determination is actually quite
inefficient and also interestingly what
we observed is that even in the presence
of a DNA binding protein if the level of
these nerd one and nap three sites is
quite low termination will actually not
occur and so RNA polymerase is actually
able to dislodge the downstream protein
and remove it from the template so now
I'd like to go over some of the
conclusions of this talk first
discussing the the technical aspects of
preparing three prime end libraries we
can conclude the quantity does provide
an efficient rapid and cost-effective
method for quantitative analysis of the
RNA three prime ends we
we found that performing the reverse
transcription at 42 degrees as opposed
to 37 degrees dramatically reduced of
the aberrant internal priming that we
observed at these imperfect a sequences
and a key point here is to is that the
sample need to be kept on the heating
block during the addition of the reverse
transcriptase enzyme how we developed a
computational filtering method that's
consistent with other other methods that
we added specific upstream filters as
well to remove the artifacts from the
poly T reads and attention reduced the
false positive results of 3 prime end
identification and we were able to
multiplex nearly 40 samples without the
20 strains in duplicate and still obtain
between 2.5 25 million reads per sample
so this allowed us to really do a lot of
biology and to uncover how the RNA
polymerase termination was occurring and
so we also were able to conclude that
the kalam sig method is capable of
mapping nuclear exosome poly a tails in
an unbiased fashion so that the poly a
tails are indeed long enough and that
these reveal the precise locations of
the nmos termination pathway we're also
able to discover that it's not just the
RNA signals the matter in defining
termination but the chromatin obstacles
or the DNA binding proteins that are
impeding RNA polymerase 2 are very
important in promoting termination and
lastly we can conclude that these common
genomic elements that bind DNA that bind
these common genomic elements they
terminated both a DNA synthesis not in
the lagging strand replication and RNA
polymerase 2 transcription and so
suggest that the cell is utilizing a
common set of partitioning element in
the DNA to regulate the genome and so
I'd like to acknowledge this work was
done during my PhD thesis at UCLA in the
laboratory of jiangshan fro and how
a lot of help with these projects from
my fellow grad students chasing and some
technicians and undergraduates as well
and I'd like to thank the Lexington
company for developing the quantity
library prep method and for
troubleshooting the protocol
optimization and we perform the direct
RNA sequencing with the Gila closed
platform would seek ll and now I'd also
like to thank my funded up funding
sources and thank you very much for your
attention thank you Kevin for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit any questions
they might have for you you can submit
your questions simply by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and dr. Roy won't answer as many of your
questions as time permits today I see
that we do have a question in our queue
dr. Roy an attendee asks why would one
want to perform three prime end
sequencing instead of fooling transcript
sequencing Thank You Brenda so that's a
good question and if we look back at the
the full-length transcript sequencing we
can see that the a large number of reads
are required to map the transcripts and
so with the genome is not well
characterized the full-length transcript
sequencing can be important to first
identify where the genes are but with
genomes that are that have been
previously mapped the three prime end
sequencing provides a superior approach
for quantifying gene expression and for
mapping the precise ends of the
transcript I see ok we do have another
question how many roadblocks for RNA
polymerase were identified in your
studies genome-wide
so we using the nuclear exosome targeted
poly a tails as a signature of these
roadblocks we found on the order of 700
roadblocks genome-wide if we consider a
cut off of one read per million and so
these roadblocks were found upstream of
these red one DNA binding sites as well
as the TF 3d binding sites in addition
to those two factors other other DNA
binding proteins were also identified in
our study ok great our next question are
the DNA binding roadblocks you found all
nine BP in gap so the nine base paired
gap that we identified if I go back to
this slide here that is that is the the
gap between the between where the DNA
replication is road blocked and the RNA
polymerase is red black and so what's
actually happening here is if you look
at the the bottom left panel the RNA
polymerase is coming in from left to
right on the plus strand and the black
bar at the bottom represents the protein
binding site and so what we conclude
here is that RNA polymerase is actually
physically hitting the TF 3b protein and
that the distance between the leading
edge of the RNA polymerase and the
active site of RNA polymerase is roughly
16 16 base pairs in this case and so DNA
replication or we can conclude as the
DNA polymerase has a shorter distance
from the active site so perhaps the
Justice DNA polymerase is slightly
smaller and so it can get closer to the
roadblock I see thank you
we have a next question I think comes in
two parts first thank you for the talk
and they asked what alignment tool do
you use for their first part the
question okay so we use the RNA star
alignment tool and this is it's great
for for mapping RNA and it's also
recommended by by lexington okay great
and their second part of the question do
you think techniques you use to reduce
the number of reads with multiple hits
can be applied to DNA sequencing so the
reeds with multiple hits these in our
case these were these are the poly a
tails that are mapping to the ribosomal
RNAs largely as well as other RNAs and
so this is really a specific issue for
for RNA sequencing and so I don't think
the techniques that we use here are
going to apply to to mapping DNA read
because their specific to to the poly a
tail which is not a part of the DNA
sequence okay we have another question
coming in how much reliable three prime
end sequencing is there in terms of RNA
quantification how much reliable three
prime and sequencing is there and in
terms of RNA quantification not exactly
sure what the question is saying in
terms of so in terms of quantifying gene
expression the the previous webinar I
think went into detail on this and you
can obtain reliable fold changes in
expression by quantifying three prime
end for our studies what we're looking
at the nuclear exosome targeted poly a
tails we're actually
seeing a very substantial change in
level so we actually use a cut-off of
five fold to define something is
targeted by the nuclear efforts own so
it's a very stringent cut off and that
so if you want more subtle changes so
such as to fold or less you will need to
have multiple replicates and utilize
some statistics to determine that the
changes you're seeing are significant so
we did not need to employ that kind of
statistics in this study because we set
such a stringent cut off I see okay I
think our next question coming in how
did you deal with our rrna contamination
in the in vitro polyadenylated samples
that's a great question so I typed over
that detail and so actually the first
time that we did it we we got you know
nearly eighty percent of the reads
mapping to the three prime end of
ribosomal RNA and that actually was you
know it's really a waste of a lot of
sequencing reads and so the second time
that that I did this we we use the
ribosomal RNA depletion kit after the in
vitro polyadenylation because these
ribosomal RNA depletion kits they
typically don't give you much kneeled so
we wanted to first perform in vitro
polyadenylation over the world of
substantial amount of RNA let's say 10
micrograms or 20 micrograms and then re
quantitate the RNA and then subjected to
a rabbit similarly depletion in this
case we used the epicenter kit for that
which has these are all ago nucleotides
that bind to ribosomal RNA to remove
them from the sample and that actually
worked out quite well I mean after that
we reduced the derived form or RNA reads
to less than five percent okay second
part
that question in a bit of a follow up in
these samples where there are a lot of
repeated poly-a reads were there a lot
of repeated poly so I think that
question is it's perhaps asking in a fee
if the ala go dt was somehow internally
priming within the Polya tail and that
would lead to a substantial amount of
poly t actually because it's reading the
poly a tail during the sequencing
reaction and will it will read a stretch
of to use so we actually didn't see any
increased prevalence of that with in
vitro polyadenylation versus non in
vitro polyadenylation and that is
mitigated by the fact that they all go
dt primer I didn't indicate it in the
slide here but the ala go dt primer
actually has a V at the end so V meaning
anything but t is at the very three
prime nucleotide and that actually
prevent substantially prevents the
internal priming of the Palio tab and so
we think that's an effective way to
reduce this done Polly Polly teen reads
that are occurring I see okay we have
another question and the ten bf's I may
have missed this but I was wondering did
you also look at if you on sequencing
can identify gene expression level
precisely I yes it can and in order to
do that again you need multiple multiple
replicates and you need to employ some
statistical analysis on on these
replicates but yes it can we didn't need
to do that in this study as I mentioned
previously but it's very effective and I
think the Lexington website has some
some software recommended for doing that
that can be done with either the Dec
software or I even believe this a new
software that they have placed on the
website okay a follow-up to that
question did you have to clip off the
first several base pairs or the poly a
tails of the reeds me so before mapping
these Reed's to the genome we we clipped
off the adapters that are sometimes
present at the five prime end so if you
look at the slide here the the portion
of the DNA here in blue is is the
adapter and so occasionally the insert
size is less than the read length so if
insert sizes to his 40 the read length
is 50 we're going to read 10 base pairs
into the blue and we want to clip that
off so we did that at the other end we
did not need to do any any clipping
mainly because the the Ala go dt was
efficiently hybridizing to the to the
junction between the poly a tail and the
genomically encoded RNA so we didn't
have to do anything there all right lots
of great questions coming in from our
attendees today compared to full-length
RNA sequencing how much less sequencing
was performed for three prime here don't
you so we have done RNA for length
sequence may as well and so the amount
of sequencing depths that you want it
really depends on how what what
transcripts you want to detect so if you
look here this is actually a very
abundant transcript it's is our key
online be at the ribosomal protein gene
and so for these samples for RNA seek we
we would obtain on the order of 10 to 20
million read which is good for yeast
will scorn seek to get an equivalent in
quantitation of quantitative level of
the transcript you would probably only
need a fifth of that so say two million
25 million reads so it is more efficient
in sequencing depth Bobby may be a
factor of five okay another attendant
asks what did you use for your sample
prep so not sure exactly which part of
the sample crap they're talking about
but initially we purify the RNA from the
cells with a single chloroform
extraction and then after our innate
purification we use the diplomacy
library prep kit part of the RNA so part
of the our nation will prep does involve
a DNA streetman to get rid of the
genomic DNA prior to that and we do a
limited treatment for 30 minutes of 47
degrees and then we purify the rnase and
then we use the collaborate prep kit
directly okay another question how often
is roadblock used for failsafe
termination of micrornas cuts and snow
rnase and do do any statistics on that
matter to do any specific over there so
we we identified roadblocks at a large
fraction of the side so so we look here
at the summary figure here we can see
that the most of the the nuclear exosome
targeted transcripts do not have this
DNA's resistance site directly
downstream however what we found is that
a large number of these were actually
road block sites but that the DNA
binding proteins just were not mapped in
this in a previous study to have a DNA's
resistant site there so in total we
identified depending on the
off between 700 to upwards of 1,000
sites of roadblocks and the road
blocking appears to be primarily used
for these cut these cryptic transcripts
or these cuts and the SAT sums up the
distinction between them it's not not
always clear but less so used for MIT
but we do find that often that
downstream of mrnas we also find road
blocking sites as well to predominantly
the cryptic transcript are the major
class I see we have another question how
do you deal with internal priming
internal priming so perhaps later they
can go through that section again in
detail but the internal priming we we
dealt with first by raising the
temperature of the reverse transcription
to 42 degrees that that reduced but do
not eliminate internal priming and so we
added the computational filter again
that's um on slide 12 here so I don't
want to go over all that again we did we
did these three steps to get rid of
internal planning after the fact
computationally I see it looks like that
is all the time that we have for our
questions we've had great participation
from today's audience I know we
appreciate it Kevin do you have any
final comments or thoughts for today's
attendee I just would like to thank
everyone for for attending the talk and
I would be happy to answer further
questions by by email or through the
elaborate mechanism that you have set up
and I'd like to thank Lexington in
particular for all the technical support
along with the the kits that they
provide and for continually developing
new products and I'd also like to thank
everyone that that helped in this
project so thank you very much okay well
thank you
seven for taking the time to be with us
today I want to thank our audience for
joining us and participating so much for
their interesting questions and of
course thank our sponsor LexA Jen for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand
through December of 2016 lab roots will
be alerting everyone via email when it's
available for replay and we would
encourage you to share that email with
any colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye goodbye